[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo Leute wir haben heute wieder einen
spannenden Fall für euch hier ist Toni
und hier ist Mirko für unseren Fall geht
es heute nach Hamburg
wir schreiben das Jahr 1996 im Frühjahr
wundern sich Leser der Hamburger
Morgenpost über einen anonym Schreiber
der im Kleinanzeigenteil der Zeitung
Botschaften veröffentlicht alle paar
Tage findet sich eine Annonce die wie
eine Gedankenblase gestaltet ist alle
fangen an mit alles Gute Ann-Kathrin
alles Gute Ann-Kathrin woran liegt es
dass du dich nicht meldest verstehe ich
Dich immer falsch
alles Gute Ann-Kathrin lass uns nicht so
lange warten alles Gute Ann-Kathrin ich
mache doch alles was du willst was ist
los
alles Gute Ann-Kathrin du musst dich
melden ich kann nicht länger warten zu
diesem Zeitpunkt wissen nur wenige worum
es wirklich geht das sind die betroffene
Familie Polizeibeamte und eine Handvoll
Journalisten hier schreibt nämlich kein
ungeduldiger Liebhaber hier versendet
die Polizei ihre Botschaften an
Erpresser das Opfer ist Jan Philipp
Bremer bevor wir zum Tag seines
Verschwindens kommen lass uns den mal
kurz kennenlernen Jan Philipp
bremsmeister damals 43 Jahre alt mit
seiner 41-Jährigen Frau Ann-Kathrin
scherer hat er einen Sohn Johann der ist
13 Jahre alt
Rentner ist ein Sozialforscher den man
den Fachkreisen schätzt die breite
Öffentlichkeit kennt seinen Namen
dagegen eher vom Tabakkonzern
ist seine Anteile hat er schon als
junger Mann verkauft er gilt also als
Multimillionär trotzdem leistet sich die
Familie keinen Wachschutz dem Zimmer am
25 März 1996 als er von seinem Wohnhaus
in Hamburg Blankenese rübergeht zu einem
Gartenhaus dass er für seine Arbeit
nutzt er will dort Bücher holen als
seine Frau ihn später sucht findet sie
auf einer Mauer des gemeinsamen Hauses
einen Erpresserbrief blutverschmiert
darauf liegt eine Handgranate die
Entführer fordern darin 20 Millionen
Mark Lösegeld und keine Polizei keine
Presse sonst wäre der Redens mal getötet
Ann-Kathrin Scherer ruft trotzdem die
Polizei und von nun an Arbeiten bis zu
200 Ermittler an dem Fall
auch in den pressehäusern machen
Gerüchte über eine Entführung eines
Millionärs die Runde aber man vereinbart
Stillschweigen und das hält quälende
Stunden vergehen
zwei Tage später kommt Post von den
Entführern ein polaroid-foto von
reemtsmart der verletzt aussieht und
Anweisungen für eine Geldübergabe
außerdem die Drohung sollte die Übergabe
aus Polizei taktischen Gründen scheitern
schneiden wir Herrn remsma einen Finger
ab aber die Übergabe scheitert weil sie
schlampig vorbereitet ist Ann-Kathrin
Scherer und ihr Anwalt können den
beschriebenen Ort in der Nähe einer
Autobahn nicht finden weil er so nicht
existiert auch eine zweite Übergabe am
13 April klappt nicht
das ist so eine verflixte Geschichte das
muss man wirklich sagen wie bitter
die Entführer Lotsen Anwalt wenn erst
nach Luxemburg und dann zu einer Stelle
bei Trier wo er das Geld über einen Zaun
schmeißen soll allerdings ist er zu spät
dran denn eine mitgereste Polizistin
hatte ihren Reisepass vergessen das
heißt der Geld sagt bleibt liegen jetzt
erhöhen die Entführer ihre Forderung
sie wollen 30 Millionen Mark und
offenbar schaltet sich das Opfer selber
ein um der Übergabe Misere ein Ende zu
machen zwei Vertraute von Jan Philipp
brems mal sollen sich um das Lösegeld
kümmern der Pastor Christian Arndt und
der Soziologieprofessor Lars Clausen
diesmal klappt alles Arndt und Clausen
stellen das Geld an einem Feld bei
Krefeld in Nordrhein-Westfalen ab es ist
der 26 April 1996
bald darauf um Mitternacht ruft dreams
mal zu Hause bei Ann-Kathrin an ich bin
frei gemeinsam mit der Polizei holen
seine Frau und sein Sohn Redens mal ab
er befindet sich in einer Siedlung bei
Harburg im Süden Hamburgs dort war er
nach seiner Freilassung herumgeirrt und
hatte schließlich an einem Haus
geklingelt wo er telefonieren konnte die
Familie will dem zu erwartenden Medien
Rum aus dem Weg gehen und verreist nach
New York was ich übrigens sehr gut
verstehen kann in Deutschland beginnen
jetzt turbulente Tage am Vormittag nach
der Freilassung gibt die Hamburger
Polizei eine große Pressekonferenz zum
ersten Mal erfährt die Öffentlichkeit
was in den vorangegangenen 33 Tagen
passiert ist
immerhin geht es hier um einen Millionär
und das bislang höchst gezahlte Lösegeld
in Deutschland die Ermittler spielen
Tonbandaufnahmen vor darauf sind die
Entführer bei ihren Anrufen im Haus der
lebensmast zu hören kurz darauf sind die
Zeitungen voll mit der Geschichte
am Sonntag schreibt am 28 April die
reemtsmalenführung 33 Tage im Keller
angekettet und zeigt das polaroid-foto
des verletzten Millionärs viele Reporter
sind schon mehr als einen Monat
eingeweiht aber alle haben dicht
gehalten die Polizei kann mit Hilfe der
Bandaufnahmen schon bald zwei Täter
dingfest machen Wolfgang kostet und
Peter Richter sie werden zu zehneinhalb
bzw fünf Jahren Gefängnis verurteilt
außerdem stellt sich später ein Mittäter
aus Polen namens piota l er war der
Bewacher in dem Versteck ah gute
Stichwort denn nach der Entführung kann
die Polizei jetzt mit den Angaben
rindsmaß rekonstruieren wie alles ablief
als Jan Philipp Bremer am 25 März vom
wohn zum Arbeitshaus in Hamburg
Blankenese geht hört er ein Rascheln im
Gebüsch zwei Männer stürzen hervor und
packen er versucht sich dagegen zu
wehren die Männer liegen im Fesseln an
verbinden ihn die Augen und werfen den
Kofferraum eines Pkw dort verbringt Rehm
zwar fast zwei Stunden denn die Fahrt
geht nach Garlstedt im Kreis
Osterholz-Scharmbeck 145 km von Hamburg
entfernt hier befindet sich ein Haus das
eigens für die Entführung angemietet
wurde das schlimme ist das Haus sieht
total gemütlich und idyllisch aus es ist
klein weiß und hat ein romantisches
Reetdach also echt schön und es hat
einen kleinen Keller hier verbringt die
33 schrecklichsten Tage seines Lebens
seine erste Woche im Keller marschiert
Rinds mal nur auf und ab seine Füße sind
angekettet er kann jeweils drei Schritte
vor und zurückgehen an dem einen Tag
kommt er auf 15.000 am anderen auf
18.000 Schritte
rindsma beschreibt seine Erlebnisse
später in seinem Buch das Gehen bekam
bald manische Züge es war das einzige
was man machen konnte erst einen Monat
später hat die Qual im Keller ein Ende
nach der diese Geldübergabe fahren in
die Entführer in den Süden Hamburgs und
lassen ihn frei zuletzt haben wir
erzählt wie die Mittäter des großen Kuhs
aufflogen aber der Haupttäter der war
noch frei genau die Fahndung nach Thomas
Drach dem Superhirn verläuft zunächst
erfolglos das ist ihn gab wussten die
Ermittler von den anderen Tätern und von
Reha der nannte Drach den Engländer weil
er im Keller immer Englisch mit ihm
sprach während die deutsche Polizei
sucht lebt Drach unter dem Namen Anthony
lalor ein Luxusleben in Uruguay da hat
er sich eine Villa gekauft fährt ein
Cabrio und hat eine schöne Frau
kennengelernt also eigentliche aber zum
Glück kommt er damit nicht lange davon
doch wird schließlich im März 1998 in
Argentinien verhaftet bis zu seiner
Auslieferung nach Deutschland vergehen
noch mal mehr als zwei Jahre
im März 2001 wird Drach zu 14 Jahren und
sechs Monaten Haft verurteilt im Oktober
2013 kommt er auf freien Fuß da könnte
der Fall jetzt zu Ende sein ist er aber
nicht denn es gibt noch mehr zu erzählen
erstens das Geld wo ist all das Geld
Rinds mal beauftragte eine
Sicherheitsfirma mit der suche vergebens
drachs Bruder Lutz der 2002 in Madrid
gefasst wird gesteht immerhin fast 4
Millionen Euro aus dem Rinds mal
Lösegeld gewaschen zu haben
er bekommt sechseinhalb Jahre Haft aber
insgesamt sind nur 1,5 Millionen Mark
der erpressten 30 Millionen wieder
aufgetaucht zweitens ein Todesfall
drachkomplize Wolfgang kostet stürzt
2014 in der portugiesischen Algarve von
einer Klippe und stirbt während die
örtlichen Behörden einen Unfall oder
suiziduntersuchen wird in Hamburg
gemutmaßt war es vielleicht Mord ging es
um Teile des lösegels dieser Fall bleibt
ungelöst drittens Drache selbst er kann
es nicht lassen noch aus der Haft
versucht er zusammen mit Freunden seinen
mittlerweile freigelassenen Bruder um
Teile des lösegels zu erpressen
die Briefe werden abgefangen drachshaft
verlängert sich nach seiner Entlassung
2013 zieht er nach Ibiza ein paar Jahre
ist es jetzt ruhig um ihn aber
neuerdings muss er sich schon wieder vor
Gericht verantworten ja der Typ ist
wirklich unbelehrbar im Februar 2021
wurde Drachen Amsterdam verhaftet er
soll nämlich im März 2019 mit Komplizen
einen Geldtransporter bei Köln
überfallen haben bei zwei weiteren
solchen Aktionen gilt er auch als
verdächtig und das sind ganz schwere
Delikte es wurde geschossen zwei
Wachmänner wurden verletzt ja aus dem
Drach wird nichts mehr würde ich sagen
und die ganze Geschichte kennt
hauptsächlich Verlierer aber ich muss
auch sagen wie spektakulär das alles ist
also ich meine von Beginn bis Ende ich
weiß noch diese Überfälle auf die
Geldtransporter da wusste man ja lange
nicht wer das eigentlich ist und ich
kann mich so genau daran erinnern als
diese Schlagzeile kam das Drach dahin
hinter steckt absurd der Typ kann es
nicht lassen ich finde also wirklich ich
finde es fast ein bisschen
bewundernswert wie dreist der ist ja das
stimmt der Typ ist fast sowas wie ein
Krimineller Superschurke und die
Geschehnisse auf jeden Fall
filmreif erstmal natürlich wegen der
hohen Summe die erpresst wurde und
natürlich auch weil Prinzip die Szenario
das Leben in der Südsee ja dass ich ein
Haus kaufen sich quasi davon machen
irgendein Land in dem man von der
Polizei offenbar nicht gegriffen werden
kann
das hat schon irgendwie so ein bisschen
was von 60er Jahre Schurken Film so ja
aber das Gute ist dass er Drach und
seine Kumpanen auf jeden Fall nicht das
süße Leben bekam dass sie sich
vorgestellt haben wer auf jeden Fall
auch nicht das süße Leben bekommen hat
zumindest nicht so wie er sich das
vorgestellt hat das ist Redens mal
selbst ich meine 33 Tage war im Keller
und er hatte ja durchgehend die Angst
jederzeit getötet zu werden
und ich frage mich will man da Rache
oder kann man damit abschließen und
einfach weiterleben es ist eine
schwierige Frage schwierig zu
beantworten wahrscheinlich kann man nie
wirklich damit abschließen und mit
Sicherheit will man die Täter zur
Rechenschaft ziehen und mit Sicherheit
ist das ein Trauma was dich das ganze
Leben lang begleitet Jan Philipp Bremer
hat sich 2006 dazu in einem Interview
mit der Zeit geäußert er sagte mir haben
nach der Entführung viele Leute
geschildert was man den Erpressern alles
antun sollte ich wollte das nie hören
ich habe es als abstoßend empfunden es
zeigte mir dass fremde Leute mein
Schicksal zum Anlassen Namen um ihre
eigenen bösartigen Fantasien auszuleben
boah was für ein kluger Mann wirklich
also mein größten Respekt nach dieser
ganzen Nummer trotzdem zu einer Größe
und eine würde daraus zu gehen und auch
zu sagen die haben keine Macht über mich
so ich bestimme mein Schicksal und ich
bleibe trotzdem ein guter Mensch ich
würde natürlich Rache ich würde es
verstehen aber diese Aussage wirklich
Respekt das hast du sehr schön
zusammengefasst und damit endet der Fall
jetzt wirklich
[Musik]
wir haben ihn recherchiert mit dem
Archiv von Bild und BILD am SONNTAG
einer Chronik der Hamburger Morgenpost
einem Storytelling des NDR sowie zwei
Interviews aus der Zeit Skript Stefan
Netzeband Aufnahme und schnitt Antonia
Heier Postproduktion durch Wake world
Studios München wir danken euch fürs
Zuhören euer Mirko und eure Tony
natürlich freuen wir uns auch wenn ihr
uns eine Bewertung hinterlasst und die
Glocke aktiviert damit supportet ihr uns
und wir sind auf ewig dankbar bis morgen